he's in front looking for a pass from Marner
Marner will try it high for neander he juggled
the puck pressured by Clutterbuck able to hang
in the zone though Matthews steps Off the Wall
hands to knee laner slid down low tapped in front
and Matthews scores a power play goal for Austin
Matthews and the Leafs take the one nothing lead
that was just Talent that's all that was was
really good quick tuck movement and the defend
the ERS almost had it out with Clutterbuck all
over KNE Lander and stick got caught just a little
bit but look at this down lit Puck movement right
here down low back out in front and marer makes
a perfect pass out to Matthews and they had all
kinds of opportunities you know what but I I think
most power plays in the NHL they're at the very
best when they're in structure coming around
for Bal that one changed directions and went
wide angal off it nice response on this shift for
the Islanders Puck available Nelson wouldn't go
samsonov down but not out comes up with the save
on Nelson that's one Nell's going to want back I
mean all he's got to do is get it up he knows it
but great shift though Brendan after giving up a
goal and it's grabbed by doson handed off here to
Nelson he'll RI it around Islanders seem to have
found their legs after giving up that power play
goal getting much better Nelson pops out he scores
Brock Nelson answers back for the Islanders and
the tie score 1-1 here not even halfway to the
first yeah really good job on the for check
the Islanders won the battle down low leading
to charge okay easy play Let's play the chip
and Chase Ang ball gets in on the four check
good support by Paul maray and watch Brock dson
slide into the slot area quick one timer Samson
off's in the net pretty deep there I feel
like he's got to move out towards the shot
he doesn't he gets stuck and Brock Nelson uses
that lethal wish s of his and ties the game up
marzel drops off for Riley cruising in Riley
moves around doy centering feet saves Samson
off as Lee got a good shot away forat will
be the first one to it holdo to the middle
for barzell he's got Horvat flying next to
him they'll cross the line together got the
pass through Horvat went to sneak it over the
shoulder of Samson of and he just was able to
stop it came down hard on the hands of Riley
meanwhile the puck continues on and it's f
fing Hudson fashing driving on Morgan Ry fashing
double team kikas and he scores Clutterbuck got
the puck to cekus just outside the grease and a
late goal in the period gives the Islanders the
Lead watch the battle along the Boors there's
Riley number two going to find a way to get it
out in the middle of the ice that's Clutterbuck
and way they go fashing making a good play keeps
it ahead of him doesn't turn it over and then
he gets some help from clutter and what a play
by cikas as he goes up in the toy department I
didn't know Casey had that move in his game I'm
going to have to ask him about that but he Zips
that one up Islanders make a change as well while
they can and then neander took it away from
buluk finds Matthews and he Rings one off the
bar no icing here as Paul Mary gets to that puck
got it to Nelson engals out in the
slot Nelson finds Paul Mary huge
scores boy this Line's having themselves a night
it's 3-1 New York what a good play getting it up
the ice in a hurry as that was Dobson I think
they were looking for a bounce play PA Mary was
going to be able to watch this play I thought
Paul Murray was going to be able to get it as
a Sam samsonov just didn't bother playing the
game at all but look at the for checking again
get it back to the point and boy boy does he
pick his spot didn't he I mean that's a goal
score no Panic let me see see if I can line it up
let me aim it he's in the slot area takes his time
and just rifles it right pass on a wrot on a very
aggressive move to the goenda off I said earlier
got to stick on that sent it aside for Matthew
shut down by soken rebound cleared away from
the net held in by Brody left side Morgan Riley
across Matthews off the bar he had soken down he
went up and he hit the post nearly the second of
the night for Austin Matthews Leaf still putting
the pressure on that's shot sails all right that's
great thank you so much and johnas popped out with
a backand that rolled off his stick berzi to
timid and the Leafs are hunting again that pass
got through for Timmons Timmons to the front TI
they score it's John Taris Point number 999 and
it brings the Lea within one and and it all starts
the H won The Face Off Brendon and and then gave
it up he's able to maintain good position first
off he gets a little wrap around but good Puck
retrieval by the leas they go D to D back to the
partner and just get this shot on that and Taris
comes and has good position on twos and it's a
nice deflection by taras but you don't want to
see the back of that using the middle of the ice
put it right on the tape of goer he can move goer
driving wide goer turn the corner where is it it's
loose just outside the crease it was in the path
of samsonov what a great strong move by go using
that speed and then his strength to drive right
in front of the net theis knocked out handed to
Romanov and now dopson with 17 touched in by Paul
Mary Nelson ties up with benoa Puck came to Nelson
his pass Romanov shoots off the post oh Big Goal
there right past the glove side then a chance for
angal blocked by the goenda neck cleaned up by MC
as he took down paulm in the end of the period a
close as was deflected along the way so Mayfield
has to deal with the yarn cro Riley pulls it
from the pair of them C locked him up hrom gave
it away and it's shot wide by Gregor that one just
jumped off the STI of Holstrom on a stick handle
and turned a nothing play into a great a scoring
chance for the lease a or Tim excuse me and a nice
little like almost like it's a good pass stolen
away cus Clutterbuck alone save samsonov and as
he's Falling Towards the goal line the whistle is
blown nander wasn't even skating 115 left nander
for Taris into the Zone Taris to the back door
it's soken an outstanding save on y the puck take
a little look here watch him swoop in right off
just all that momentum see that again Brendan same
thing and he wins it 13 seconds left that shot
goes wide cleared out to the front KNE Lander
his shot T rebound they done it with 6.4 seconds
left it's Riley who ties the game for Toronto
all right just poron in got it the two and it's
bounced but it's the faceof win that starts it
all again watch the faceof win and the Islanders
trying to block that one of Ricochet a little
bit and Islanders just miss getting it out
but there's the there's the fuit is Bounce
you get outnumbered down low there's not much
you can do about it bounces off see if there's
any kind of interference there D is right at
the top of the circle I'm sure they looked at
it well what a play that was by Mitch
martyr long stretch pass it's Matthews to the net
he shoots kicked Away by sokin and he defended
the rebound to now it's barzel and Horvat in
a two-on one barzel with Horvat pass there sh
scor the Isles give away a point and then they
get their second Bo horback the overtime winner
well it all starts with you know who number 30
makes a big save Matthews and Marner with the
opportunity and barzel puts the Jets on a perfect
little saucer pass and that one's up in the toy
department also another Big Win For The Islander
and you know what the hockey guards rewarded them
they played a really good game against a very
good team Tonto got a lucky bounce at the end
to tie it and the Islanders get a big save and
a big goal by corvac and it's a huge win for the
Islanders B Horvat scores his 10th
goal of the Season barzel gets the
primary assist doson the secondary it's
a three assist night for Noah doson no